The next important property is that it's actually secure,
and we're going to focus first on secure against a passive eavesdropper,
so this is an adversary that can listen in on all the messages
but can't modify them.
That means the adversary will be able to get the public values q and g.
We'll also be able to hear all the messages transmitted,
so we'll be able to learn yA and yB,
and our goal is to be confident that the adversary
would not be able to learn k AB.
The question is which of these would be most convincing
in proving that the Diffie-Hellman protocol is secure?
The first is that showing that the number of possible xA values to guess is too high.
The second is showing that an attacker who could solve a known hard problem
would be able to compute the key.
And the third is showing that an attacker who can compute the key
would be able to solve some known hard problem.